hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heutige seinen ganz besonderen kuchen
und zwar mache ich mal einen gesunden
kochen an isu erhoben gesund denn der
kuchen hatte weder zucker noch mehl
zucker hat er wirklich nur von natur aus
und zwar aus den bananen und aus den
früchten aber ansonsten habe ich kein
haushaltszucker mit rein gegeben und
kein mehl das heißt dieser kuchen ist
auch glutenfrei und die basis sind
einfach bananen und eier dann kommt noch
entkommen doch mandl mit dazu die sorgen
für die festigkeit und der kuchen ist
auch wirklich sehr locker also ich hab
dir neulich bei einem kochkurs
zubereitet mit den teilnehmern und der
kam auch wirklich sehr gut an
das heißt man kann ja schon so viel man
möchte nicht geschwunden ja und ich
zeige euch jetzt kurz die zutaten für
den teig brauche ich viel reife bananen
als sie dürfen ruhig richtig reif seien
sechs eier einen teelöffel zimt etwas
man in der extrakt zwei teelöffel
backpulver 300 gramm mandeln und dann
brauche ich noch ein paar früchte ich
habe zum bern und team werden jeweils
etwa eine handvoll also ich mache das
alles jetzt in einem mit da ich nix da
diese matic dörfer länder also den
hochleistungs mixa aber ihr könnt auch
jeden anderen mixa nehmen ich nehme es
nur den weil ich die mandeln selber
nochmal möchte so ging zuerst einmal die
mandeln hier ein und ist auch ein weg
ich richtig schnelles rezept jetzt
einfach kurz der kleine
die mandeln fühle ich hier ist kurzum es
geht wirklich super schnell da braucht
da wirklich nur zwei bis drei sekunden
jetzt gebe ich die flüssigen und zutaten
rein also jetzt erst mal eier und da
kommen auch direkt die bananen mit rein
und die reife die bananen sind unsere
süße kuchen
denn ich habe ansonsten keinen zucker
mit drin so also griffen schon so
richtig schön braun sein
dann kann auch direkt das vanille
extrakt mit dazu und davon gebe ich
gerne etwas mehr ein damit der kuchen
noch richtig tolle strecke jetzt legt
sich erstmal die flüssigen zutaten durch
auch ganz kurz nur ein paar sekunden
und jetzt kommen die restlichen zutaten
mit rein als die mandeln danach das
backpulver und das zimtpulver da muss es
einmal noch kurz durchgemischt werden
also dass sich auch kuchen den männer
machen ganz schnell alles nur gemixt
jetzt fühle ich den teig in eine
vorbereitete form und zwar habe ich
einen bug rahmen auch 26 cm größe
eingestellt jetzt wo der teig fertig ist
auch der mur ag.com hätte auch früher
kommen können nennst du nämlich den teig
gemacht wieso ich es um idiotensicher
teil
das habe ich nicht gesagt ob es schon
einfacher tag lasse klar dass in der
wixxer und fertig ich hab hunger
ja du kriegst du gleich einen gesunden
kuchen jetzt kommen auch die früchte
obendrauf
und da könnt ihr an früchten nehmen was
ihr möchtet was ich gerade da habt ich
habe jetzt die brombeeren genommen weil
demokratie mit den blauen vertauscht hat
ja ich ein bisserl verwechselt
die vom regal ein blackout gehabt ich
wusste was tun wenn johannes wir heißen
alle so komisch die können da übrigens
ein tiefkühlfach nehmen oder zum
beispiel kirschen auch aus dem glas also
das schmeckt wirklich alles sehr gut und
ich habe jetzt auch bereits den ofen auf
180 grad ober unterhitze vorgeheizt
und ich backe den kuchen jetzt für etwa
35 minuten bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
aber es sollte auf jeden fall die
stäbchen mit dem zahnstocher machen
der kuchen ist jetzt fertig und
abgekühlt also für mich wird er noch ein
bisschen puderzucker drauf gehören aber
wir machen ja einen kuchen ohne zucker
also da geht wirklich sehr schnell
ich habe alle zutaten in einen mixer
reingeht geben und also zubereitungszeit
hat mal wirklich maximal drei bis vier
minuten dann noch die backzeit und immer
wenn man mal lust auf was süßes hat kann
man sich finde ich diesen kuchen machen
vor allem ist raten naschen ohne reue
raschen ohne war bmw wie die leute von
brigitte zeiten nachstellungen die räume
ich überhaupt einen gefallen sei ich
verdient ein stückchen ab nicht nur
gespannt
aber ich bin ehrlich sagen ja auch ein
paar andere müsse mit reingehen wenn man
möchte also man sieht jetzt auch ganz
gut ich nehme ins amt das er auch schon
locker ist und schön saftig
bitte sag jetzt sieht es ist schön
aussieht also bis sich also schön sie
dann eher da sich viele die schon sagen
aber dafür dass ein gesunder kuchen ist
also ich fand ihn sehr lecker fernsehen
schwenkt die prom beschränkt also
despoten hier richtig tolle farbe
probieren und wie gesagt wir bereits am
anfang erwähnen sie reifer die bananen
sind umso süßer ist dann auch der kuchen
es muss daran denken bei der verkostung
ohne zucker und mehl
ich würde sagen ja
man schmeckt schon also gesucht ist also
ich hab ihn mit den teilnehmern im
kochkurs gemacht und er kann echt gut an
natürlich schmeckt dann nicht so wie ein
normaler koren also mit zucker und mehl
das schmeckt man finde ich schon
deutlich raus aber ich finde gesagt bin
gesund bin ich echt gut
aber ja
schmeckt wie schmeckt mir erfurt
raufaser mit kirschen
falls ihr diesen kuchen nach machen
wollte jeder block 2 steht die zutat
noch mal ganz genau
und dann wünsche ich schon mal ganz viel
spaß beim nachbacken und ihr könnt mir
gern mal eure meinung schreiben
gib mir das stückchen kuchen meinen was
ich finden gut geschmeckt
ich will ja ich hab gut